make america boring again president
trump with this prediction
on life if joe biden wins the presidency
if you want depression doom and despair
vote for sleepy joe biden
and boredom if you had sleepy joe then
nobody's going to be interested in
politics anymore that's going to be the
end of that
they will all go out of business they
should have gone out of business four
years ago then i came along
all right brett you've covered it all
we've had special counsel we've had
impeachment we've had a pandemic we've
had riots we'd have trade wars
border crisis kavanaugh there's got
there's got to be a group of americans
that might just say you know what
i just might want to be bored
it's one of the pitches jesse for the
biden campaign
honestly in and that is no chaos
yeah like for the people who are
exhausted from
reading tweets or reacting to the thing
of the day that's that goes to 11. uh
but i do think that there is
a real dichotomy here of of people who
think that the policies for
president trump and what he's done what
he's doing what he would do
are on one side and then what he says
and what he tweets and what he
whatever on the other side of the paper
and
it depends on which side of the paper
you're more focused on
some people are focused on the policy
stuff and for those people
they don't care about all that other
yeah juan to that point it has been a
very results oriented first term there's
no denying that but
you you will have to admit it's not just
trump's personality that's caused a lot
of the turbulence in the last four years
this constant clash with the media with
the democrats it's just
it's it's warfare open warfare 24 7
that does create a less-than-boring
atmosphere
uh well i think we've had people who
have had antagonistic relationships with
the press before
this is a president who has to say to
suburban women
or housewives as he calls them won't you
please like me
i mean the the fact is that so many
americans want us to get back to normal
want to get away from the divisive
rhetoric that comes from this president
and the twitter tirades
so they just want somebody who they can
have faith
and trust and think is a role model for
their kids rather than someone they have
to explain away to their children
greg would you like to uh react to what
juan said
everything that he just brought up is
about words
and not deeds so we're not actually
talking about real exhaustion
we're not talking about getting up at
4am to milk a cow
or drive a truck across country this
exhaustion
that people are complaining about are
over tweets will god help you turn off
the damn twitter machine and if you're
so exhausted by donald trump oh you poor
little baby
you know there is going to be a shift
it's going to be a shift from
bad words to bad deeds because the one
thing we don't know
about joe is what he's going to do in
the face of like
the woke the woke crowd who want to drag
america away from its capitalist origins
into some kind of strange abyss in which
we're all faced in this
ongoing witch trial of oppression what
are we guilty of
and that's going to be the way the
country is going to be under joe because
he has no
spine at all worry about the deeds don't
worry about the words
dana here's how i see it it's pretty
simple are americans ready for another
shot
want another shot or you want to have
some water and go to bed early
i think some people might want to drink
some water and go to bed early
but i do think the american people they
like how the nights go and they want to
do another shot
oh oh my gosh wow
yeah i just think that i'm like the
wrong person to ask because i can't hang
at night and you know that so
i feel a little bit like it's impossible
for me to answer that um
can i say one thing about exhaustion and
this desire for
normalcy i think that there's something
that people just
just keep bear with me people for a
second those watching
i understand that you're frustrated that
it feels like things are so divided and
you're looking for a role model but i
i honestly believe this that if you are
looking for a role model for your family
that you have to set the best personal
example
nobody else can do that for you like and
i think there are better ways to
think about bringing people together
than worrying about what's happening
at the white house on twitter etc that a
lot of this
really comes back to how can you be the
best possible role model for yourself
for your family for your employees for
your neighborhood for your community
because that's really how america became
great in the first place